thank you two floors you have this cute
floor sign we have in LA and London and
Singapore is opening up its really thank
you you know what I'm buying up like
crazy like like crazy this is my
favorite thing I'm buying right now
football cards no this cones are Collins
yeah I am buying so many Colin Kapernick
rookie cards cuz you know they're gonna
cuz the sports card market is pricing it
as of him being an inactive player right
what is but I think he's a cultural icon
right so like in 15 years when it's gone
yeah you know how it started I start in
the safe in my safe behind you I have
like eight Jackie Robinson rookie cards
get out of huh so I've been buying up
1948 Jackie Robinson Ricky card it's
like crazy because I literally by the
way where I'm going I think sports cards
are about to become cultural like
sneakers my son I just you just
yesterday was waiting for Amazon to come
he had bought for his birthday he bought
how old 8 yep he's I mean we have
baseball cards all over our house has
that always been the case where is this
just starting no I mean I your dynamics
a little different or a while but like
he's really not really what episode is
it it's our new it's super in problem go
into and do some calls as well
ok I'm it's you will follow along it's
very easy
hey everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 316 of the
askgaryvee show and I'm really excited
about this episode for a couple reasons
one I've been on vacation for two weeks
which means I have so much pent-up
energy that I want to get out into the
world so I'm excited about that but more
importantly we have a really really
interesting show for you if you're
watching on face were you taking a phone
calls from Andy
okay so Instagram I know you're watching
over there if you want to get a question
in you're gonna have to go to Facebook
or YouTube where we're live on both
those platforms and put your phone
number in and he's gonna grab some phone
calls but before we get into all that
stuff I'm gonna let these two lovely
guests introduce themselves give you a
little context about who they are and
what their books about we're gonna I got
some questions and then you'll have some
questions thanks for being here thanks
ladies first okay I'm charlie Jeter
co-author of the stuff but also
president of the turn two foundation I
work for my brother Derek which most of
you know or may know and I'm just
excited to be here thanks for having us
yeah of course yeah Samson Davis I'm an
ER physician co-author of this stuff
I've written a few other books as well
and travel country and speak often and
just excited to be here
so let's first before we go even deeper
into you individually just cuz the way
you guys set up what what is the stuff
about what is this book about well the
stuff is an inner fortitude it's
something that we believe every person
is born with is the ability to overcome
huge obstacles and challenges in life we
think far too often especially young
people but everybody but it goes into a
situation with the idea that they
already cannot accomplish it and so what
we wanted to do with have lost before
they've started exactly and so when is
that conditioning from parents
environment DNA oh yeah and one of the
things that I'm making my plea to be the
third author and the stuff to do you
remember the Spaceballs the movie yeah
yes do you know that they had a sequel
it never got made but it was called
Spaceballs 3 the search for to subtitle
- a secret right anyway all of the above
right so what we wanted to do is we want
we went around we interviewed different
people who had overcome humongous Hobson
and for everybody who's listening
because it was funny I yesterday a woman
came up to be during a charity
basketball game she submitted something
for our for k-swiss campaign and she's
I submitted my challenge and then the
video came out and knows were real I was
like talking about like having two knee
surgery people were like talking about
real [ __ ] mm-hmm but just for context
for like what are some of the challenges
that people overcame in this book I mean
we have many stories when we share our
personal stories and then uh challenges
that we face we have a person in a book
who was burned over 90% of his body was
given a greater than 100 percent
mortality rate at age he was a teenager
and his mother asked him do you want to
live or do you want to die if you want
to live you have to fight and so he
chose to fight obviously and he survived
and he overcame given a mortality rate
over 100 percent that's almost
miraculous that he was able to kind of
overcome the situation from from a
medical standpoint and I have a question
I have a feeling this gonna be a tough
thing to answer but I but I'm you just
inspired me to ask and something I think
about so much how underrated is the
brand is the brain in our current
society when it comes to genuinely you
know I you know obviously there's
diseases and things that are just it's
kind of a math thing but like I'm
fascinated by what you just said because
I'm uncomfortable and how much I believe
it right and where I'm going with that
is I just think you can we'll [ __ ] into
existence I mean your attitude is a big
big part of it and how you sort of
approach it your confidence and seeing
that glass as half-full and really
believe in that you could persevere and
overcome your situation is a big
component of it now and granted there
are medical conditions that are
challenging in if somebody rips your
heart out of your body right MORTAL
KOMBAT
even though I'd be sitting there being
like I'm not gonna die I'm probably
gonna die at that point at that point
you can see yourself yes but it is I
mean keep in mind how advanced sort of
studies in literally that person laying
there 50 50 a 70/30 not gonna make it
matter I've never even heard of
mentality so like you know but like that
70/30 person has there been enough data
on the woman or guy that laid there and
said [ __ ] this I'm gonna win and what
that variable is versus what most people
hear is like oh my god 70
percent I'm done like has there is there
any advance yeah I mean the studies have
shown I don't know any particular study
but what I do know is that studies have
shown is all about you added to me of
course the medical condition is its
variable so the medical condition or
whatever you have been diagnosed with is
situational but your attitude and your
approach and your conditioning if you're
going to choose the exercise and believe
in hope and actually gonna overcome and
beat this situation yes it will happen
now if you're gonna sit back and
diagnosed with something like I'm not
gonna take this medicine right about
something super interesting you know
like I don't know any of the details on
the Steve Jobs thing I write headline
reading like I remember thinking like
hearing like maybe he did some
alternative stuff right from the again
and I was mmm I'm that kind of person so
let's make sure I don't make that kind
of likely right I took note of that to
your point you know it's very
interesting we're having this
conversation it kind of makes me think
about all the [ __ ] that I pop out into
the world which is like look everybody's
listening right now to make a contextual
for you you have a certain level of
natural entrepreneurial talent no
different than sports talent no
different than anything else but but the
perspective you deploy changes the
outcome to the maximum of what that is
and and and at times I'm even with this
stuff at times it may not be at the way
you want it to be but its nursery its
developing its everyday processing and
putting energy into it and as you do so
then your belief and the growth of what
you can achieve and how you overcome and
how you could persevere rather its
medical personal life professional it
starts to develop and take flight who
were you as a kid yep
I was tomboy and but I was somebody I
was raised a very close-knit family had
parents that told us we could accomplish
anything I say I was very fortunate
because they wouldn't let us listen to
the outside world you know and hear but
also to you know you can only be
shielded for so long he has to go out
into the real world which is what I was
hit with when I went off to college did
they do a good job you know it's funny
because I saw Andy react to like not
here in the outside world it's something
I talk so much about what my mom
and dad did for me as well yeah did they
do a great job in practical optimism
like like did you have like that
optimism like I can do anything but were
they great at not creating delusion yes
very good at it right because isn't that
is that your perspective on that like to
me what is so fascinating is in the
current state of parenting the reason we
have 8th place trophies is we took you
can do anything but we created fake
environments right we eliminated
accountability and that's why we're
skewed the other way now right and to me
it's the balance of practical I call
practical optimism right or just like a
limit a limit when you tell your kids
you can do anything I think where the
parent really needs to be thoughtful is
when that kid then goes and sings at a
talent show and sucks [ __ ] you can tell
them they're Beyonce right
you can't because what a lot of people
are doing is you came in you didn't win
this talent show but it was the judges
fault it was a bad night they like to
start creating excuses at scale and now
you have 23 year old writer who entered
the world full of excuse framework well
I mean a really interesting story is at
an early age Derek went off to school
and said his dream was to become
shortstop for the New York Yankees
he had teachers this is 8th grade I
believe he had teachers that said to my
parents that you need to put real
thoughts into his head and my parents
turned around and said he had in our
mind he has real thoughts yes but it
works well that point there no he wasn't
great really but it was he has to work
very very hard and they told him that
they said if this is what you want to do
you can accomplish it but it is gonna be
very very hard for you to for you to get
there you're gonna have to work really
really hard and put your all into it so
that's where you have to be realistic it
is a possibility my mind works hard I
sit in the way he says it my 6 and 3/4
year old son is obsessed with basketball
and he talks about it 20 talks like me
24/7 every second it's after 2 weeks of
vacation just now like like my music
teacher in first grade called me
motormouth and I'm watching it in my
opinion but he already in the
six months I've got him and like he he
already knows that he will never dunk
right as a kid and the little basket in
your house you're dunking like crazy and
six months ago I was like bro you will
never dunk he cried he was devastated
like for a week it was like tormenting
him but he is now taking so many [ __ ]
jump shots and he's like dude he's like
do you think I'll be in the NBA I'm like
I don't think so
but if you work ridiculously hard and
miraculously become the first person
that can hit jump shots from half-court
because I think you're 510 likelihood of
your life is going to be a challenge on
the evolution of like everybody being
seven feet in the NBA mm-hmm I just
believe in that [ __ ] but on the flip
side is is there an opportunity to show
him those who were shorter than six foot
he's made he thinks he's Steph Curry he
already knows who spud Webb is of course
there is right but it's also using what
he has so he's using his ability if you
can't don't then he's like I wanted well
it's really interesting right like all I
talked to him about is jump shooting and
left hands like like if he's gonna be
any prayer of even like a decent d3
basketball player like he better [ __ ]
shoot his ass off and better have a
ridiculous left hand you know what I
mean like you know so like it's it's
just this conversation which is like do
not create delusion however what caught
my attention when you were going there's
when your parents tell you could do
anything that everybody who's
accomplished something remarkable
basically either had that or such the
reverse that they were like [ __ ] you
that it drove them but that person tends
to get there and be unhappy versus the
person that you know and so there's a
positive framework nonetheless how about
you well my state where I grew up
yeah asking host yeah origins I'm really
big on comic book number one like that
series of questions for me is gonna be
predicated on where'd you grow up how
you know like it helps me understand how
you got to this stuff it helps me it
helps Andy pick the next couple
questions I'm fascinated with context
right right so where were you born and
what kind of kid were you yeah I mean I
was born in New Jersey where on
north-north New Jersey
in Newark New Jersey grew up in Edison
okay oh yeah I went to school at Rutgers
and not too far yeah so but I was just I
was in just an ambitious kid I know what
I think I just had this kind of inner
driving for you when I felt that way
over 46 keep there so that doesn't drive
to just really just become something in
life I can't really explain it I just
really believed in life that I can do it
now I grew up single-parent home with
five siblings but it was challenging
environment but at the same time like I
knew that I wanted to be something now
what that something was I had no clue of
course I would love to play baseball but
you know that position was taken already
so but um were you a sports kid yeah
played I play baseball yeah I play
baseball basketball
I have a few articles in a small paper
you good at school yeah I was I was
school came easy yeah you know me like
it was something that I enjoyed knowing
but it wasn't a cool or popular thing
right right right so you know you would
always sort of hide or not really crash
about you know what I got a 95 right and
so it just was it was this drive to
become something to achieve something in
life and just kind of moving along and
as life took me it just became an
opportunity or opportunity presented
itself to go to medical school and to
become a doctor now I didn't know what
the heck what the hell that doctor did
besides pediatricians and giving shots
and everything I didn't know the details
and so I just went for it because it was
something more than what I had in front
of me and so intuitively felt like a
proper step forward right and I enjoyed
helping people and I like you know I
will always have a job so let me go for
it and do and in that career path have
you maintained the same passion you know
obviously you know speaking and writing
you're scratching other things then you
know you're passionate about like how's
the you know a lot of people who watch
and listen to this are in you know are
attracted to my message because I think
back to you can do anything but it has
to be practical there
what has happened you know three of us
are far closer in age than a lot of
people in this room and a lot of people
that are watching we did not grow up
with a mature Internet that actually
allowed us to have unlimited options in
perpetuity around our core interests and
that is what's happening now yeah so I
guess the reason I'm asking you now that
is I think there's a lot of people
watching who eventhough in the passion
of the career choice they've given and
when they're in the dip they're thinking
about should I start my side hustle or
thing have you you know I'm just very
curious about what you're doing with
this and what your career is it's a very
fun question for me to ask have you
maintained that love for it has it never
fully been there because it was like the
opportunity to win an advance has it
ednan flowed how is your love for that
profession navigator of last 20 years
yeah that's a that's a very good
question I think it does or it has
evident flowed in the sense that I enjoy
medicine but I also enjoy speaking also
enjoy writing books like this is the
fifth book that I've written so I enjoy
the progression of what's next the
evolution which is unknown because you
really don't know you know your passion
is to achieve and to be successful it
might be within a career aspect of what
you're doing but at the same time I
enjoy the aspect of life or seeing what
sort of presents itself as the next
thing and you don't often know what that
is but you just kind of follow the flow
of just applying your formula of success
and seeing it grow and develop so yeah
practice of medicine and being an ER
physician and saving lives and rescuing
people how to feel the first time you
save somebody's life oh it's it's
amazing it's like you have your own
theme music you walk out and it's like I
would see any level of like trauma and
blood I would literally faint hey you
know when I walk into hospital sometimes
and get lightheaded walk in the front
door of the hospital so this is the
beauty Bob
but God the beauty about life is like
the first time I saw surgery
I lost my lunch in the scrub saying you
know yeah yeah and so I'm in college
like okay I chose the wrong
I like [ __ ] like laughs like there was
no right to pass interesting like did
like some mentor company be like don't
worry I did that too they were just
laughing at you were like how did that
the nurses get it you got to go you got
to get out she kicked me out of the ER
there's no joking
yeah but then but that's what I'm saying
like this is what I think sometimes
hinder us as people is that we go after
something we believe in we sort of
receive a message that this is it for me
or suit challenging micro adversity we
take it as a macro that's right you grow
it as monster in your mind to be bigger
than what it is you know pursue it and
then boom it's like now you're not
reaching you let me talk about this I
don't know if you cover in the book
actually there's two things two things
one if you got phone numbers YouTube
Facebook we're about to do calls to I
want you to give me five bullet points
of like takeaways for the book cuz I
want everybody to buy it but before we
get into that you know we're you know
we're here because you and I have hung
out a couple times and we vibed and I'm
like oh [ __ ] we see the world the same
way and so I've been excited about this
but excited to meet you so I'm leading
the witness a little bit here but but
this micro failure as a macro how much
do you think the current state of
demonizing failure in our society early
on leads to enormous issues or
vulnerabilities to what we're referring
to like do you let me ask it in a
different way
do you believe that we need to start
beating a drum of especially at a
parenting level to start really
embracing failure much earlier which
then won't make somebody who loses their
lunch there are actual people on earth
who lost their lunch put in all that
time and effort into medical school loss
or lunch went home called mommy and
daddy and decided to become a lawyer
Yeah right but then when they're they
become that lawyer to what they need to
know is that they're gonna hit that same
point in a different way on that path
and that's what we're that's where we're
shortchanging our kids it's like failure
as a part of success you
half I will fail I want to excel point
at something you're going to and because
when you're what's happening to you is
they're not just changing their careers
a lot of people are going off to college
and they've been told this whole time
hope you're about to fail let me go and
do something else and they don't realize
that when they go and do that other
thing they're gonna get to a point where
they fail at something so many people
are jumping out of windows you know I
mean it's it's they're going off to
college and they cannot manage once
mommy and daddy aren't around them
anymore
yep or another version of that I see
people who on their third version of
college because they only want to stay
in that environment that and the MBA and
doctor and lawyer and I'm like you
[ __ ] love practice 39 names like Gary
I've got these 76 to play and he could
like shot I could sue me and he was like
a friend from back and day and he's like
you know what do you think I'm like you
love practice what do I think I think
you're [ __ ] 39 years old and you love
practice you have to take flight yeah 17
beautiful diplomas in an office you
haven't done [ __ ] yeah you don't leave
one [ __ ] game what do I think I think
it's obvious [ __ ] right yeah yeah I
wanna me I not only want to make failure
in equal to success I actually want to
celebrate failure as I've said this a
lot in a lot of different ways you wanna
hear something crazy actually to make
this very meta Charlie Hayes catches a
ball in 1996 the Yankees win the World
Series yeah and I have not watched a
full Yankee game since and I grew up a
massive New York Yankees fan the New
York Rangers won the 94 Stanley Cup
right across the street there and I
never watched an another 90 I I
literally stopped watching my team's
after they win a championship forever
I'm so about the failure and the process
the reason I love the Jets so much is
how disaster day
I'm loving the mix now this is real good
now you know and and I think maybe I and
I actually not maybe I think I oversee
you that way like if you really watch me
as an entrepreneur something nobody in
the outside who's watching right now
only mark you out getting my lawyer my
financial people I do so
many things to sabotage myself or like I
pick kindness over success or did many
other things because I love losing I
genuinely am not kidding when I back to
growing up in Jersey in those kind of
places going to a pickup basketball game
picking teams and losing the first game
was always my dream because I love the
feeling of trying to win the second game
I enjoy the feeling of trying to win a
second game of pick-up basketball or a
set I liked tennis a lot and I was good
at it and one of the reasons I was good
at it was I had a ridiculous record of
winning the second and third set in
comparison to almost anybody else on my
team or like the coach had seen because
I actually believe what I'm about to say
I think I actually threw the first set
subconsciously not you know because I
enjoy adversity see that's that's
exactly it so you you are good we're
living in an uncomfortable space no no
I'm [ __ ] great I love the feeling of
yeah whether I'm great or good at it
no no it's my most comfortable like I
matter fact even the way I carry myself
cursing or things that nature I have
come to learn recently last five three
two years oh [ __ ]
I enjoy being misunderstood up front I
love the great unveil I love the I told
you so I love the you didn't think so
[ __ ] you and not in like the kind of
like [ __ ] up way more like the showman
way like like you know what I like I
like the wink I like when I do something
you didn't think I could then I look at
you and I wink and it's like a funny
thing not a [ __ ] you you're you know
more like a right you know mm-hmm
which what is that to bring you like to
bring it back and then just bring it
back what you're saying and and that was
why it was so important when we talked
about and we interviewed people for this
book was there are so many stories that
you hear about you hear about what
happened to them and then the success of
it yes and what we wanted to do because
all of the interesting stuff is
the middle how did they get out of it
what was it like when they hit rock
bottom like what we want to hear that
they were at a point where they thought
they could not overcome surely what what
these are such macro tough things
hmm ninety-eight nine point eight
percent of the people listening right
now aren't gonna have that level of the
you know adversity potentially it's huge
it's they're number one they're like
yeah but also to the reason why we
wanted it to be so so to the extreme of
a tough situation is how many times have
you watched something on TV or story
about someone you're like wait a minute
if they could get through that right and
what I'm dealing with is possible well
not only that I will argue that the
single reason I'm always happy is every
single reaction to everything that
happens in my life that is a negative is
or my wife and kids could get hit by a
car right now and die like I go every
time I'm met with anything that isn't
fun business-wise I go so extreme and
feel it mm-hmm that that's exactly right
like what people do when those kind of
stories like right I understand that
right that's rework of a perspective
were you born that way you feel or is
that something you developed I don't
know I think I was born that way
cuz I I absolutely believe in like DNA
you know but I think environment yeah
you know I was very aware that my mom
lost her mom at five and my dad lost his
dad at sixteen since I was six I can
tell you that mm-hmm like very aware I
can tell you from seven to nine I had 15
20 times a year nightmares that my
family was going back to Russia for a
family reunion and the plane crashed and
and I was the only one with one random
family member each time it was always
different that survived and we got to
walk through the snow like Rocky and you
know in Rocky four so clearly like death
of my family and like that kind of stuff
has always been a framework and I don't
know I feel like I was born with certain
thoughtfulness and meta macro [ __ ] but I
also think the fact that both my parents
lost a parent before they were 16
probably played as narrative in my mind
yeah and also say it sounds like you
embraced the fear
yeah bro and honestly a lot of like not
being able to speak English and going
and you know a story I rarely ever tell
is when I'm you know I don't even talk
about Dover I lived in Dover for a year
before he moved tennis and I was talking
about Queens think about this think
about what you guys are hearing right
now I always go Queens to Edinson truth
is it was Queens to Dover for a year to
Edison I don't even know why and you
know and now that it was so bad but
there's one real story I will never
forget I go outside I can't speak
English and these six kids and I was
five these six kids made me drink piss
out of a Pepsi can and I think about it
so much because I can feel this second
37 years later exactly how I felt and
how I felt was you [ __ ] are confused
you're laughing and you think you've won
you have no idea how this is gonna play
out mm-hmm and and and that wasn't
taught right I don't think I don't know
what my mom and dad were doing in Russia
for this but I can't believe that that's
what I you know I didn't think about
that until like ten maybe ten years ago
that's crazy that that's what I thought
because as we know extreme bullying and
picking on leads the masses into a very
dark place it led me into a very great
place which was I'm gonna learn how to
speak English I'm gonna [ __ ] dominate
and I'm gonna one day tell this story on
my podcast yeah you know things like
that you know like you know kind of
thing ya know I mean that's a and that's
exactly I mean it's it's it's two ways
obviously either you can sort of meet
the challenge and rise above or you can
let the challenge destroy you and
surrender to it and obviously you did
the the thing of rising above man I mean
that's exactly how much this has to do
with you giving a [ __ ] about other
people's opinions I mean some of it has
to do with that but so it's also how you
perceive it you know how you how you
sort of internalize it and so yeah other
people opinions even though it's
sometimes it doesn't matter it does know
intuitively and obviously I think that
plays a lot into it I think people you
know take an L and it's actually other
people's booing hmm especially maybe the
parent like the top five people that is
really what scares them that if nobody
knew about your law
mm-hmm would it really matter it's kinda
like the tree in the forest like at the
end of day like when I lose I don't have
an ability to give a [ __ ] what my
parents my wife my kids or my best
friends think and in that is the great
liberation of being able to do anything
but you were raised in a different time
so you remember we are raising kids
nowadays I mean not me personally but
that they can't lose that they get an
award preaching for it right so if they
if they have it then they are never
allowed the opportunity to say they lost
so why wouldn't they run from you every
time they see it you're preaching
questions what's doing it I get it I I
can't get off of 8th place trophies I
know I can't get off of it
I am completely and utterly convinced
that a stunning majority of the mass
depression anxiety fear and jumping out
of windows yes it has nothing to do with
social media or iPads right has
everything to do with parents that want
it to over coddle their kids which
created and put them into natural wild
hi mrs. Valley I'm sorry I couldn't
answer your call right now sorry I
believe that I believe we have an entire
generation of zoo animals grant and I
think the second those animals
understand they are instead of this is
where it's funny so I I go after the
parents but then to the kids I go cool
but instead of being upsetting your
parents forever now you take over and
[ __ ] own it and reformulate right
mm-hmm
you took the trophy just funny friends
parents said the kid didn't take a
trophy I'm sorry the person you were
trying to reach has a voice mailbox
[Laughter]
Alice yeah you called back yes I pressed
the wrong foot and when the phone rang
hurry no apologies needed where you
and please say hello hi how are you
hello I'm from Miami Florida and um
thank you for taking my call by the way
I want to talk to you about because it's
just like I happen to get on YouTube and
there you guys were and it just hit home
so hard
I am almost 48 I grew up in a family
that migrated from Cuba success story
great very supportive I grew up knowing
that I could overcome anything and I was
very very successful until I got ill a
few years ago got out of that and um my
dad got sick and I've been dealing with
all this stuff now and all of a sudden I
feel like I don't know what happened to
be old me I'm paralyzed I don't know
what I'm doing my life all I know is I'm
just getting day-by-day
you know I have the financial media
doesn't everything but that's not
important I'm missing my drive again my
motivation to want to suffer
I feel like paralyzed I understand
thoughts guys or questions for Alice
that might be able to build con context
yeah I think Alice whatever it is it's
it's something there's some trepidation
that you're facing I don't know
specifically what it is but it's it's
sort of embracing that and accepting it
and dealing with the pain of whatever
that may be and is also then formulating
strategies to overcome and to sort of
find that dry within yourself rather is
exercise yoga meditation reading you
know sort of writing into tactics that
become tangible doing that become
gateway drugs to the unlock there you go
okay exactly
now something I get a lot of immigrants
can I do you think that or maybe that
you overvalued financial success given
the framework which would make a ton of
sense and then when you dealt with your
own health issues or a dad what ended up
happening at this young of an age you're
like wait a minute
[ __ ] money health and happiness and
maybe the reframe of what you thought
success was is what you might be dealing
with well you're right because you know
what I realized when I got sick gonna
find the answer and there was those
dollar amount in the world that could
find me the doctor earth or whatever so
I felt like how can I you know a bit so
successful may look funny you have all
the support and I can't get
and then my rock which is my dad yep I
come out of this and now he's sick and
I'm like oh my gosh I did I mean I'm
sure I can't fake it you know it's funny
I've got crazy goosebumps because I was
listening to you know I was like so I I
said something like five times on
vacation last two weeks and the first
week back we're now Thursday I was in LA
that first three days had different
business meetings and eight times
because I counted eight times in the
last three days in business
I said I'm starting to question if I'm
driven by money at all I've always known
that it wasn't the biggest thing I'm
starting to get scared that I don't give
a [ __ ] at all I am aware that I you know
think back to I love the chase like I
love the chasing the Jets not buying the
Jets and then equally I don't give a
[ __ ] about money which is a problem if
you want to buy the New York Jets cuz
it's gonna cost four billion dollars but
as you were talking Alice I was like
[ __ ] and this is why I just want to
chase happiness and I put health on a
crazy pedestal and I think I think you
just might be going through a maturity
mentally Alice I actually think this is
gonna unlock the greatest thing ever
I'm making assumptions and alluding to
things that look parents tend to pass
before their kids when you have an
emotional Rock in that big of a
relationship you fear that loss so so so
much but to be very very frank with you
Alice as you were talking I was getting
happy not sad I actually think you're
just levelling up
I think the reason you were happy before
was you were trying to win a very short
game which was money which came
naturally to you because of lack of fear
and talent and skills and hard work I
just think you're evolving and I think
you're gonna start going for fulfilment
you're right yeah you know what a mess
you talking I'm saying you know what
you're asking me right now it's like
where do I get my jump might use my
adrenaline though I think you're gonna
get it from impacting other humans I
genuinely think humans have either
selfish selfish selfish or selfless
behavior I think that I'm happy because
I have so much of both I'm so ambitious
for me and I've so much want to need to
leave a legacy and that's why if you
look at
how I'm rolling over the last three
years especially it's so obvious right
which is why people take different hot
takes on me you know like I'm the genius
and best I'm a narcissist and the worst
like I get it because I'm pulling so
hard at both and I think what you did
was you pulled so hard for you financial
success now you have this in-between
phase where you're starting to get real
calibrated on what actually matters my
guess when I run into you an airport in
16 years is you were so right I started
this nonprofit I started this for-profit
nonprofit I started this school I I did
this thing with these 50 women I have no
idea but I have a very funny feeling I'm
right well that's great thank you for
telling me that because you know what it
really opens up you know a new scene
glass if you will but yeah you're right
that's I mean I've always said you be
back is the best way you know come out
of things when I love this you're gonna
love this the way that you were
successful in business and people talked
about ideas and you laughed at them and
you said yeah but it's about the
execution people talk about giving back
is the best thing ever and they don't
give back that's exactly it
that's exactly it is that they might do
it was money or a check but not with
them bingo
you know how much more fun it is for me
to write a $25,000 check to a charity
than sit down with some kid for 30
minutes the minutes matter to me that's
be given the [ __ ] back well especially
in listen listen house a lot of people
are listening right now and they're
saying easy for them they have it you
know and that's true by the way like
like a lot of things in life are easier
once you've checked one of the boxes
you've wanted you know a lot of people
have money correct a lot of people
correct a lot of people say to people
easy for you know this person to say
they have money and then I say to them
yeah but look how happily married you
are that person isn't so you have
happiness and love like you know there's
just so like everyone's judging without
understanding everyone's got their
shortcomings
and the reality is we've all got our
process I think the serendipity of life
has created two data points for you that
reframed your perspective and the reason
you're struggling to get it back is you
will never never ever again care about
the money the way you did before
it won't happen no it should downsize my
cart everything changed and now I'm like
wait a minute you're right you're
absolutely right it's just when you know
you can have seven chips you don't want
seven to a hundred thousand [ __ ]
percent thanks Alice you know thank you
thank you bye bye does it get you guys
pumped when you hear the clarity in her
voice I was like wondering what you guys
were thinking you know like sometimes
you know when you talk to somebody
you're like they do not get it yeah
actually was a leader you awaken
something in her you could tell that she
was like wow somebody gets where I'm at
and understand what I'm going through it
was funny when she was talking I'm like
I got this one yeah you know like you
know sometimes you just know sometimes
just know yeah
while Andy's dialing this next number
before you hit it Andy one or two macro
thoughts about what's in the book for
the audience that might bring them value
yeah well I mean one of the things that
we talk about in the book is just having
a good support system around you and
that doesn't have to be your family see
that second part one more time so it
doesn't have to be your family because I
think that's where people check out
right away why didn't come from a
supportive family my family's not here
and so I'm not gonna have that supports
a mom but sometimes it's not your family
it's a friend who's just there to kick
you in the butt you know and say look
you can do this get off your butt like
it's time to go it's okay to grieve it's
okay to be down and it's okay to feel
like you failed at something but now
it's time to get up and do what you said
you know you're motivating me like I'm
literally sitting here thinking about
this a lot you're saying something so
awesome and you're saying it's okay to
fail it's okay to grieve and no joke
what's going through my head is like if
I was think about like literally you're
talking and Annie surrounded me and I
was like picked it's so funny how the
brain works I'm picturing me and Andy
hanging out somewhere and like what's
coming out of my mind is forget about
it's okay to grieve it's okay it's more
like no
this is good this is [ __ ] awesome
like I just want people to embrace their
scarlet letters like I wish I had that
[ __ ] scarlet letter from that book I
would have [ __ ] Superman that [ __ ]
[ __ ] you like I want to make it awesome
not adequate like we to your point where
we are in society right now is like
let's take it from negative to it's okay
right we're having this great mental
awareness like thing of like it's okay
let's let's take away the stigma and I'm
on some [ __ ] of like [ __ ] the stigma
adversity is the foundation to have
unison success yeah that's I mean you're
saying you're lucky runs you're lucky
your mom's [ __ ] up I'm gonna say it
one more time is that I really want to
throw a fun challenge I'm because I'm
appreciating that I have you guys to
bounce this off of I want to argue this
in a fun way I am convinced that the
things we've alluded to earlier the
perfect situation that has so much
resources and so much good that it's
over corrected so much to make you a zoo
animal is far more vulnerable right now
than the person from a fucked-up
environment or purse like I'm telling
you I can sense it because what the
Internet's done to us yeah has you see
where I'm going is look at you you're an
african-american male 46 like like I
don't I didn't get into the details but
like whatever the circumstances are
Rutgers and medical you're a wit you
know you your natural talent school came
easy to you not to me your work and all
that stuff but like [ __ ] man do you like
do people understand that we don't need
the government grants the the lucky tap
the lucky or untestable de pon the like
everybody that needed somebody to unlock
the gatekeepers are gone yeah the
Internet's the gatekeeper the end that's
the validation yeah the audience can be
the validation right not the luckiness
that their next-door neighbor's friend
would like was like you know
crazy but I also think too that we're
are you calm
okay I also think that too we're in a
situation now where it when you say
there's this perfect environment I mean
we have to realize at that perfect
environment they're still life so I go
off to college and my senior year I was
she'll I believe I have the best parents
in the world they shielded me they
protected me but they also taught me you
know right from wrong and to work hard
but I go off to college and I get
diagnosed with cancer they can't control
it Derek's money can't fix it for me I'm
out there and I have to deal with life
and that's what I'm saying is that they
can have this perfect environment but
life is still going to hit them and
they're gonna have to figure out how to
deal you know maneuver it and it doesn't
matter what their environment was
growing up as what about people that are
wired like me which is the number one
thing that would have ruined my life is
if I was the children of me as somebody
who only wants to build and his process
right and like every other normal human
as much as I want to shield out other
people's opinions you're still a human
if I was born into a situation with all
this natural talent
unlike sports where you've got to prove
it out even if you're LeBrons kid in
business it's cloudy and if I had
parents that had extreme wealth my
entire career would have been I was put
on third and a half base you didn't do
it and it would have destroyed my life I
tell friends from the hood and the
streets all the time I know you envy the
trust fund maybe who's on a yacht and
Ibiza on Instagram right now that kid is
[ __ ] if that kids a winner or has any
ambition for themselves that kid is so
[ __ ] up when he goes to sleep you
don't even know of course everybody has
their [ __ ] there is no perfect life
right right I believe that I I know I
literally believe that I would be
extremely [ __ ] up as a person if I was
born into every exact same thing who's
eight on
I never share your [ __ ] Instagram
stories but when you gave love to your
little sister here I had to share it
yesterday about this show I would agree
you never share my Instagram well here's
my question first of all big love to
everyone in that room my question my
question is and this is gonna be serious
and Charlize and really surprised when
I'm about that Charlie and I go back 23
years I've never broached this topic
with him I was there when her diagnosis
came and her brother told me about it
shortly thereafter her brother and I
another friend Mike flew to Atlanta to
kind of be with her and raise her
spirits but I've never asked her what
what her mental spirit was in terms of
acceptance of the disease the initial
fear and taking it from you know the
fear to the fight and what that process
was and how it affected her later
success that's my question actually I
genuinely believe that Eitan will go
down in history as a as a prime example
of what a friend looks like I think he's
more talented at being a friend then
almost anybody I've ever seen in life
right I genuinely so to answer your
question a ton first of all thank you
for being a part of that team that came
and supported me I do remember that
weekend very well and eight tons
forgetting to say that he also hosted my
21st birthday party in New York and him
and Eric they flew all my friends in to
surprise me during a snowstorm to lift
my spirits so I appreciate that you know
it's it's interesting a ton because I
wrote this book off of the discussion me
and Sampson had about how I did not ever
really process what was going on and I
it was almost like I was in not so much
denial I knew I had to get treatments I
knew I had to deal with six months of
chemo but I
stayed in school and decided I was going
to continue commuting back and forth to
Jersey or New York to do do um chemo at
sloan-kettering because I didn't want to
stop College I didn't want to leave my
friends I didn't want to move back home
so it wasn't until a few years ago when
we decided before we decided to write
the book that I was kind of woken up by
Sam's I don't know if you want to jump
in but we were just having a
conversation about it we had never
talked about it before and I was like
you guys friends like give this some
context for everybody's listening why
were you having a conversation yes we
both have our own foundations run
foundations and his foundation honored
me for the work that I do I got to know
each other I met met him and I hired him
and his friends to speak to all of our
kids in our organization has their story
was so impactful yep got it and we were
on a flight home from one of our
baseball clinics in Tampa and he started
talking about this book idea he he had a
book idea but it was more along the
medical side of things and I and I was
like come on Sam don't make me read
another medical book I'll read it to
support you but look why don't you do
something that everyone can relate to
and I don't even remember how exactly it
was brought up but he brought up
something about me going through
treatment and how I was one of these
people who had overcome adversity and I
said no no no no no like I just didn't
want to leave college and leave my
friends and go back home like really I
truly believable that yeah I did not
want to stop life and he's like but the
fact that you look at it that way is so
strange you know it's it's not normal
that you just say oh cancer okay well
I'm just gonna stay in school and finish
up and take a flight back and forth
which luckily I was fortunate enough
sure my family support me to do that but
um you know it was it was eye-opening
for me to know that I actually had
something inside of me that would that
had prepared me to go through that and
that was why I was on this search
through doing this project to find out
what were those things that I had inside
of me so that I could use them moving
forward so I could teach my son about
them and and teach others about it
because that was important to me with
our foundation work with teaching kids
how they
you have these things within them and a
lot of times we suppress them we don't
even know they exist
yeah within us yeah hey Tom thanks for
such a great question bro all right guys
take care yeah let's sneak one one more
in let's seek one we're in well Andy's
dialing anything else we want to talk
about because I want to give as much
context well one of the other sort of
ingredients with the stuff is Ford your
motivation statement which i think is
very important they're sort of having
your own mantra I think then whatever
you're going through life and where
you're going you need that motivation
that constant reminder to keep pushing
yourself and there should be something
very simple
I used three DS dedication determination
and discipline and I feel like that is
ironclad and it can help you to sort of
get you to where you're going because we
all are on this sort of journey in life
you know we know our destination we all
have the same destination ultimately and
is what you do with that - in the middle
you know so no I like that what are you
gonna do with that - in the middle so
you have to stay motivated and you have
to find something I don't know just see
me Sarge something I didn't I haven't
shared with my audience or really even a
lot of you I think the team knows my
grandmother passed away four or five
weeks ago and I've talked about my
grandma publicly here and there about
like being a tough kind of character and
like having a path even my dad but it
still is what you know it's and it's
funny the - in the middle hit me so hard
cuz I spent at that funeral ninety-eight
percent of my time looking at all these
different tombstones and just looking at
dates yeah and just like and like
looking at that - in the middle yeah you
know and that's key and that's it that's
nothing but that's where your happiness
and your joy and everything lies it's in
that journey and you know what I think
also with life and now being 46 I
started to see your perspectives of what
your desires are on what you want
changes you know it's sort of that's the
best part
yeah and so we did with Alice yeah
that's the best honestly yeah you
say this I secretly hope I wake up one
day and don't want to work ever again
and just do some like [ __ ] weird Yoda
in a [ __ ] Mountain [ __ ] like this
audience gets so big and that I'm just
in like Peru in some like and don't you
have to like figure it's like a game you
have to figure out how to find me but if
you find me I'll [ __ ] break it down
for you like people you know retirement
that's the that's of being half pregnant
I'm like I'm either doing this until
like I'm 97 and going and you know or
I'm going [ __ ] weird as [ __ ] like
weird like my own little weird like
weird I'm telling you it's gonna be on
the record if I decide not to work every
day of my life until the day I die and
try to win Super Bowls and buy the jet
all that I'm gonna go weird or then Oh
what the you know how like something
like Howard Hughes these people become
recluses I'm gonna be the good version
of that
I'm gonna go weird but positive weird
not like ramen okay we're in nails can't
wait this year every kid come through
but I'm gonna challenge you to find me
yeah I've got some Waldo [ __ ] I can't
wait Jimmy Jimmy it's Gary Vee this is
Gera this is Gary Vaynerchuk I am not
kidding Jimmy oh I'm doing really well
you're on the show please say hello to
Samson and Charlie hey everybody hello
what's your question
Oh question yes so I think thing out of
jail my whole life and then you know I
saw my new coat repair company or than a
probation out here in Chicago
and I can't practice all night doing
daughters my wife and my business as
well as I want to because of other
things that doesn't pass what can I do
I've got a thought but I don't I've been
talking too much because I've been
excited to have you guys here once you
guys take your baths
I've got a thought you say you can't
focus on all cannot focus because
he's dwelling on what's hanging over his
head in his past and my opinion is he's
he's so over worried of something that
has he has no control over cuz it's
chapter 1 2 & 3 and the reason chapter 4
5 & 6 can't be successful is he keeps
reading chapter 1 2 & 3
instead of writing chapter 4 5 & 6 bro
that's your answer that's your answer
let me give you something crazy about
society Oh Gary what you're saying is I
need to stop reading and then be you
start writing I need to pick up the pen
and put the book down that's right what
what I'm also telling you is bro it's
not 1974 in America anymore nobody gives
a [ __ ] that you've been to jail right
when I tell you this I hope this is the
line that [ __ ] breaks open your life
you cannot believe what I'm about to say
nobody gives a [ __ ]
the stigma as a matter of fact I like
you more now you might you know mainly
cuz you've been in and out of jail so
I'm making assumptions that it hasn't
been the most extreme [ __ ] you know like
you know it just been done you've been
doing dumb [ __ ] not like [ __ ] all
time I hate you [ __ ] so like i weirdly
think that you're using the excuse of
your past to not let yourself be
successful and that's why you're losing
everybody comes up with some excuse
building a business is hard [ __ ]
you understand
and so I [ __ ] love it I just can't
put the second time in that I build that
wall that can't laughing I can't do it I
can't do that
but I'm dwelling on the other
commitments that I have to make to the
state of Illinois you know that's it bro
you mean you know what's amazing about
life bro you did that [ __ ] that's why
Illinois has a [ __ ] Vig on your head
guess what that's what you got to do and
it's who will pass you know keep in mind
it will pass but you do have to work as
Gary mentioned towards your next
chapters of life and you have your
family you have your career I mean you
have already achieved so just embrace
that aspect the positive side of it
don't let the negative or what has
happened in the past that has shaped you
believe it or not it has shaped you to
be where you are I mean I share real
quick
story I did I was it locked up and
incarcerated as well as a juvenile and
you know and thankfully Newark life and
I just got the way from Gary stock door
you know if I wasn't seventeen and a
half my story would have been written
differently so that didn't stop me
talking about 4:40 literally a half a
year a half a year so what would have
happened and I would had an adult charge
I would had a sort of you know a real
true federal number or number that would
have prevented me from coming yeah it's
becoming a doctor and this is all
environmentally shape how I grew up and
being surrounded by what I was
surrounded by but at the same time
instead of that to your point instead of
that sort of you send a message that I
could not do it it sent the message that
I have to get on this crusade and make
these next steps and write this you know
I might be sick of the crusade
see Gary says a lot of things that
really hit home to a lot of people and
one of them to me is being the I'm
always the sword you know one we looked
at around towns and wow he came from
nothing he absolutely left and his
parents are dead he's got this hot [ __ ]
does he do it
but then after about eight months of
just non-stop [ __ ] work I give up
right I just think I get the [ __ ] so
I'm like I'm gonna take two weeks off in
two weeks or two months and then I'm
[ __ ] broke again mm-hmm I think I
think something that I'm obsessed with
brother is and this would make so much
sense to me this is why I tell people to
chase something they like versus chasing
the money one of the reasons you may be
giving up is you might have the talent
to make the money in eight months that a
lot of people admire the problem is you
don't [ __ ] love it right okay I'm 33
years old I've been sales my entire
[ __ ] life phenomenal in sales out
stand by everything I say yes I [ __ ]
hate it I like to cook I like to see you
know man you're coming into the
restaurant on their big night and seeing
them happy with the [ __ ] meal I
provide them I don't want to sell people
should know more so now let me give you
a really good piece of advice if you
just
patient which is hard when you have
illinois's Vig on your head when you've
got three kids that watch it when you
watch it when your wife watch it when
people are watching with all the things
in life but brother if you get slow and
patient how old are you 33
this is so fun this is so fun for me bro
if you slow this the [ __ ] down you can
cook and make tons of money for the rest
of your life because you got sales
talent which is a gift and you can cook
your [ __ ] ass off for the next 75
years all you have to do is not value
money for the next 36 months and eat
[ __ ] to build the foundation to make the
cooking make the money money never
motivated me I want to do my passion but
like you said I got a 16 year old a 7
year old in the three month year old
being 33 it's a little difficult here
with four girls in my office at all
times I got a cool I get it so now you
have to have different conversations
with them this is where you can bless
them when you're like hey fam here's
where we're going we're gonna all
collectively eat [ __ ] for three years
you don't like it tough [ __ ] we're gonna
we're gonna eat [ __ ] collectively for
three years it's gonna shape you so
you're not a loser and dad's always
providing for you so you're gonna win
and dad's gonna get into a good place so
we can do it forever so let's all huddle
up on three
say eat [ __ ] and for the next time put
enough and and and for the next three
years
I'm gonna build bricks which are maybe
not gonna allow you to get the new
Supremes or maybe we can't go to the
best hotel at Disney or maybe you're not
gonna get those [ __ ] fly Fila dad
shoes but here's what's gonna happen
we're gonna [ __ ] do it and we're
gonna win forever instead of up and down
up and down I built for myself and I
admire in others when they've created a
framework that makes them play and with
happiness in perpetuity not up down up
down and everybody's out here up down up
down in it you're doing great until
you're not right I'm sick of it because
you're up downing it bro you're making
something you created a framework that's
not sustainable it's it's creating
profit to allow you to kind of achieve
this over
ahead of four people and Illinois but
then you burn out what you need to do is
go the other way and eat [ __ ] for three
years to foundationally build your
restaurant chain franchisee one-off
high-end place or cooking model or
cooking school or there's a million
things you can do but you're gonna have
to eat [ __ ] for three years financially
which is tougher to 16 year old tough
for you and your wife I get it but it is
the only answer for you to create
something in perpetuity absolutely you
know what my wife's gonna kill me if I
stay on the phone but I feel blessed to
be able to talk to you today Gary and
everyone there with you thank you bro
hope you have a great day I have a go
bye bye guys
parting thoughts and then you get to ask
the question of the day any question
that you want answered from the audience
parting thoughts no I mean first of all
thank you so much for having us we
appreciate it
I you know my parting thoughts would
just be that our goal I we talked a lot
about giving back and doing things that
make you happy but I truly believe that
by living your life to do things for
others and to look at those that are
coming behind you is something that is
fulfilling and it's um a lot of people
don't realize that they think that if
they have a ton of money to give back
that that's what's going you know you
just give back and it has to do with
money and you talked a lot about giving
your time and I I do feel like that's a
huge part of success I feel like it's
something that's necessary in order to
overcome things is to find a way to make
it about more than just yourself and so
that would be probably my parting
thought yeah I mean I agree I uh thanks
for having us in but I also feel that
this the evolution of time and how we
progress is that the the goal now in
life were the goal of life as it stands
this moment is to really follow your
purpose fine you're calling what it
stands for and everything else will sort
of come along I think our generation
growing up it was always go after the
careers become this become nice yeah and
and I think you know it's changed so
much and technology has really helped
with that as well just just the
acceptance of it all yeah it's the frame
right it's the framework of why and it
all starts with why right so
I mean I think you have to find what
that why is not your what and really
pursue it and you know and that's really
what I'm learning now at this day July
you know what I liked that you brought
to the table here and I'm curious if
it's in the book cuz I think I'll bring
value because I'm very macro I thought
you were pressing the whole way on this
podcast tactics like create your motto
you know right I like to go super macro
and then tell everybody watch me I'm
giving you my tactics and my actions
right you have to watch me differently
but I'm gonna talk macro right you know
I thought you did a really good job in
multiple times going into and then do
this and then do this and I think doing
really matters back for that joke I made
earlier about like you love practice
right that's the structure of the book
is 11 at core elements and then that's
what we try to do is walk people through
how to do it but don't tell them how to
apply it to their own and I think the
tactics is just bullet points you write
again you tell you a story but we're
also just like when in the marathon you
get a cup of water long source but you
have to run the marathon yourself you
have the coursework in what's your
question that day you go cuz I that's a
tough one this is a question for the
audience yeah yeah cuz then they'll fill
in in the comment section their answers
which might be like a good research and
development thing for you yeah I think
yeah I think the question is what is
your fear and how do you overcome your
fear how do you face your fear so let's
actually I'm sorry to jump right in but
we've done this once or twice one of the
most interesting things that I've done
in my career as a public figure is this
question I genuinely believe that when
people actually say their fear out loud
to the world that they've taken back the
leverage and really believed in I really
believe it and it's super hard yeah it's
as hard as it gets you can get a lot of
fake answers you're gonna get a lot of
second thing that they fear third thing
they fear because the number one thing
they fear is probably putting out
somebody they love out that's the truth
yeah that's the truth and that's hard
man I really love that you said your
support system doesn't have to be your
family I wish people knew how to put
into the proper like department their
family because they could have such a
healthier life with their family and be
happier themselves
said of them being miserable and hating
their family they can accept their
family for their shortcomings and they
can be happier right and also true
they're not blaming because see I think
we look at other people's lives and we
say oh well they succeeded my life
doesn't look exactly like that so I'm
not gonna succeed and it's it's a lack
of accountability even your parents who
had the biggest outcome it's still you
you've heard this podcast or this video
right now now means it's on you yeah now
you heard it yeah so it's on you right
once you take that it gets so good right
thanks for being on thank you thank you
thank you go on this episode we get deep
awesome that was